jusque là martine aubry guy bedos
bonsoir martine aubry vous êtes donc à
l'origine de cette initiative avec votre
association agir qu'est ce qui vous a
donné dans l'idée de vous lancer dans sa
tente dans cette affaire est ce que sont
ces jeunes qui sont venus vous voir est
ce que c'est vous qui les avait
contactés bien c'est plutôt guy bedos
qui est venu voir la fondation agir
contre l'exclusion en dix ans je
souhaite faire quelque chose contre
l'exclusion et on a eu l'idée de monter
un spectacle d'essayer de faire parler
des jeunes de ce quartier de vaux en
velin de leurs données pour une fois la
parole pour qu'il parle même de leurs
conditions de vie du chômage de la
drogue des difficultés mais aussi et je
crois que c'est ça qui est formidable et
touchant de leurs rêves de leurs espoirs
et on a ce spectacle absolument
formidable à la fois drôle politiques
touchant extrêmement touchant grâce au
talent de guy bedos qui les a beaucoup
aidés du réalisateur didier vignali je
crois que c'est la première fois qu'on
voit sur scène des jeunes de banlieues
qui parle effectivement leurs problèmes
et de façon extrêmement moderne et forte
guy bedos bonsoir je vous ai déjà
entendu raconter votre premier contact
avec ces jeunes au début ils vous ont
pris quand même pour quelqu'un qui
venait comme ça pour se faire mousser
peut-être non mais c'est celle qui
chantait chaude et je vais ils en ont vu
d'autres donc comme ils sont très
intelligents très instinctif et bien ils
vont très vite
et ça s'est arrangé assez vite entre
nous qu'est-ce qui a fait que ça s'est
arrangé à un moment donné vous leur avez
dit quelque chose où ils sont aperçus
que vous étiez avec eux y avait vous
savez je crois qu'ils sont assez apte à
reconnaître la sincérité de quelqu'un
est bon ça m'est difficile de dire là à
la télévision que je suis un homme
sincère mais je suis quand même ça sert
on vous croit sur parole ils bedos juste
avant le reportage sur la cigale je
résiste pas au plaisir de vous en
parlait il ya les comités de soutien à
monsieur lionel jospin il y avait des
artistes
la semaine dernière il ya des gens qui
se sont rassemblés autour de monsieur
jacques chirac des gens qui étaient
disons à gauche avant que monsieur bergé
ou frédéric mitterrand ça va vous
inspirer sa non dans les jours qui
viennent mais ça m'inspire je suis sur
scène un peu partout qu'est-ce que vous
enviez un tournez à gauche ce sera
difficile il est trop tard dans le
journal pour vous le dire mais mais j'ai
effectivement tout ça
le spectacle de la comédie humaine et de
ces élections présidentielles m'amuse
autant qu'elle sa luge monsieur pasqua
mais peut-être pas pour les mêmes
raisons
qu'est ce qui vous a inspiré dans ce que
dit monsieur parce que tout à l'heure
or mais moi je fasse quoi il est parti
vous pouvez parler il avait des choses à
ferrals dans le spectacle il faut qu'ils
viennent un soir d'ailleurs parce que ça
devrait la muse et tout ça on il est
beaucoup question de lui de sa police
sans manichéisme
mais tout de même avec vigueur alors
partie de bruit ça vous fait beaucoup
risquent dé guy bedos qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous alors est ce que vous
êtes
interrogé sur ces ralliements la de
l'entourage de monsieur mitterrand au
tour de monsieur jacques chirac
je crois qu'il faut pas faire trop
attention aux paillettes ça change pas
fondamentalement ce que pensent et j'en
ai d'ailleurs les artistes tout à
l'heure qui soutenait lionel jospin en
parler du fond plutôt c'est à dire les
solutions qu'il a au chômage au logement
etc
je crois que ce spectacle est plaint des
problèmes de ces jeunes et je crois
qu'on apporte une partie des réponses
donc il faut venir à la cigale on est là
pour parler de ça ce soir il ya eu un
questionnaire balladur il ya quelques
temps
et bien ce spectacle est une réponse
c'est une réponse au questionnaire
balladur bon et répondre aux les vivent
bien m'écouter jours merci tous les deux
donc je rappelle que ce spectacle
commence donc à partir de ce soir
la cigale à paris on va